- La couronne nord demeure
le royaume de la voiture.
Le transport en commun n'est
pas toujours une option
intéressante, comme en témoigne
cet homme qui attend l'autobus
pour aller à Montréal.
- S'ils pouvaient mettre ça
à une demie-heure, j'aimerais
ne heure, c'est assez
long à attendre.
- Dans le sud de Lanaudière,
comme à Terrebonne ou
Repentigny, à peine 6 % des
résidents prennent le transport
en commun chaque semaine,
alors que l'auto solo estle moy%
de la population.
Les citoyens veulent plus
de transport collectif et
souhaitent la venue du Réseau
express métropolitain.
- Peut-être que des fois,
je délaisserais l'auto et puis
que je le prendrais.
- Je pense que c'est une
alternative qui est absolument
nécessaire et souhaitée.
- Le prolongement du REM
de l'Est dans Lanaudière,
c'est ce que réclament aussi
les maires du secteur,
qui ont organisé un forum
sur la mobilité.
NICOLAS DUFOUR,
maire dey
- Nos citoyens, pour le moment,
n'ont pas d'alternative à l'auto
solo. Ils ont le train de l'est,
mais qui a très peu de départs,
donc s'ils avaient
structurant, fiable, fréquent
et pérenne, là, les citoyens
embarqueraient dans le transport
en commun.
- Invité sur place,
le ministre des transports,
François Bonnardel, confirme
que le projet sera étudié.
Le REM serait prolongé jusqu'à
Mascouche, on l'arrimerait
possiblement avec le train
de banlieue déjà en service.
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL, ministre
des Transports du Québec
- C'est sûr que le prolongement
jusqu'à Mascouche, je pense que
c'était très attendu. Il fallait
y répondre, parce que ces élus,
autant que les usagers,
se sentaient un peu orphelins.
- Mais pour l'instant,
pas de tracé officiel,
pas d'échéancier, pas de budget
prévu. Même si le projet n'est
qu'embryonnaire, les maires
de la région veulent y croire.
- Donc, on est très, très,
très confiants.
- Par ailleurs, Québec s'engage
aussi à étudier le réaménagement
du carrefour des autoroutes 40
et 640, et à ajouter des voies
réservées pour les autobus
sur ces deux autoroutes,
ainsi que la 25.
MATHIEU TRAVERSY,
maire de Terrebonne
- On va rester vigilants
et on espère que M. Bonnardel
va rester longtemps au ministère
des Transports pour faire
le suivi avec nous là-dessus.
- À quelques mois de la
prochaine campagne électorale,
le ministre des Transports
annonce que plusieurs projets
seront à l'étude, de quoi
réjouir les maires de la région.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Rep